The key observation is that this thing over here is n!/(n-k)!
and to see this let's go back to the case where we had 4 heads.
In the 4 heads case, we multiplied all the way to times 5 over here.
We only multiplied all the way to 7. These are the 4 heads that we placed.
So n! goes from 10 all the way to 1. (n-k)! goes from 10-4 and that's 6 all the way to 1.
So this blue expression over here will go from 10 x 9 x 8 and so on all the way to 1
over now n-k, 10-4 is 6. 6*5*4 and so on.
When you look at this, the 6*5*4 occurs on top as well.
So we can cut those out and what remains is 10*9*8*7. This one over here.
Now once we place these 4 heads, we have to divide by a 4 factorial
which is different ways of placing those 4 points into the predefined bins.
So put differently, this is k! so if we put all this together you get n!/(n-k)!*k!
This is the expression over here. Let's practice this one last time.
Say you have 125 coins and you ask how many ways exists in which 3 coins come up heads.
What is the resulting outcome? Be careful when you use your calculator.
It might result in an overflow, but the answer is easy to compute.